la vie de ce rassemblement touche à sa
fin comment se passe la vie ce père sion
et bien l'ordre de dispersion était
donnée il ya une vingtaine de minutes
par les forces de l'ordre qui ont menacé
les derniers manifestants ici un place
denfert rochereau il reste très peu de
manifestants à quelques antifa ont
réussi à s'intégrer à s'introduire en
tout cas dans le cortège de
manifestations génération identitaire
c'est d'ailleurs eux qu'il reste à
présent ici à quelques slogans hostiles
envers le mouvement génération
identitaire si on devait faire un bilan
de ce rassemblement
aucun débordement massif à signaler
puisque un important dispositif de
sécurité avait été mis en place tout
autour de cette place denfert rochereau
l'objectif était clair pour le mouvement
un génération identitaire c'est à
protester contre la procédure de
dissolution lancée par gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur
je vous propose d'écouter à ce sujet les
deux porte parole du mouvement nous
voulions rappeler l'importance de la
liberté d'expression et la liberté
d'association dans ce pays qui sont
actuellement gravement mises à mal par
le gouvernement et par les radars man en
particulier qui souhaite dissoute
génération identitaire pour des raisons
bassement politiques d'une part mais
aussi à travers nos finalement il ya une
volonté de criminaliser le discours anti
immigration dans ce pays
or on peut encore à être hostile à
l'immigration en france sans que ce ne
soit ni condamnable ni motif de
dissolution tout simplement que
juridiquement parlant à gérald darmanin
n'a pas les outils pour dissoudre
génération identitaire cette lettre de
qui a annoncé notre dissolution elle
s'appuie sur deux chefs d'accusation qui
était la constitution 2010 d'une part et
l'incitation à la haine
sachant qu'en fait pour l'opération que
nous avions menée dans les alpes en 2018
où nous avions déployé une bande une
frontière symbolique entre la france et
l'italie
nous avions eu un procès pour
effectivement constitution de milices et
nous avons été relaxé par la justice en
décembre dernier donc la justice elle a
déjà tranché pour pour ce chef
d'accusation là et en ce qui concerne la
situation allait nous n'avons jamais été
condamnée non plus pour ce chef
d'accusation nous n'avons jamais eu de
procédure judiciaire et où les propos
que nous avons jamais pu tenir ont
toujours respecté le le cadre de la loi
et la liberté d'expression quelques
personnalités politiques se sont
également rendus ici en place denfert
rochereau afin de soutenir le mouvement
c'est le cas de florian philippot
président un des patriotes qui dénonce
de son côté un procédé anti démocratique
écoutez je suis persuadé que la raison
pour laquelle darmanin
lendemain annonce la dissolution des
générations identitaire c'est une
polémique est née au sein des troupes
dans marche
suite à sa phrase un peu polémique quand
il a dit en direct à marine le pen qu'il
la trouvait trop molle ça a choqué on le
sait on a vu la polémique beaucoup de ma
chronique beaucoup de ses collègues au
gouvernement qui ont été choqués par
cette phrase il fallait donc qu'il donne
des gages qui montraient qu'ils étaient
bien là en rempart contre l'extrême
droite entre guillemets et donc il a
annoncé la dissolution de génération
identitaire donc c'est pour ça que je
disais voilà vous êtes victime de ça
vous êtes la victime de ça bon après il
ya d'autres raisons plus lointaine mais
vous êtes victimes d'abord de ça le
calendrier à mon avis explique
totalement par cette phrase le
rassemblement statique touche donc à sa
fin ici un place denfert rochereau
la manifestation qui je le rappelle
était statique ici elle dans le 14e
arrondissement de paris ca déroulée
plutôt de manière assez calme quelques
débordements je vous le disais un quart
à quelques antifa ont réussi à
s'introduire au sein du cortège pour
provoquer le mouvement génération dite
identitaire mais très vite appréhendé
par un effort de l'ordre puisque voilà
vous l'entendez dernièrement à l'ordre
de dispersion était redonner une
nouvelle fois par les forces de l'ordre
un important dispositif de sécurité
avait été mise en place
ici place denfert-rochereau afin
d'éviter tout débordement est ce qui a
été le cas